so it's not every project you guys get
to work with a cast like this I mean I
have to see you two together but legends
like living legends on set with you what
was it like where'd you learn what do
they learn from you Wow um
that's a great question um no I think I
mean like you said the cost on this and
the creators behind it are so phenomenal
yeah and one of the things that really I
think drew me towards this project was
not only was it an amazing script but it
did have such an incredible caliber of
people behind it I don't think everyone
was cast when we started auditioning but
definitely once we got the whole group
together you walk into a room and it
just it kind of it took a second to just
process like you know this really is a
cast like a really old star ensemble
cast and it was such a pleasure to like
work with everyone I think it's a little
when you walk into the room like you
wonder what's it gonna be like and and
you know for me like everyone on this is
I just appreciate and I'm inspired by a
lot of people's work on this but at the
end of the day you also realize like
everyone's just a really lovely human
being and so to have that on top of
being really talented is is wonderful
and makes for a great experience yeah
how does your approach to your character
into a scene adjust between your prep
and on the day when you get to say be
across of Don Johnson it's giving you
what he's given you
that's a good question yeah I don't know
I all obviously it changes I think the
the feeling and the the tone of the
story changes once you're on set because
you're surrounded by other actors who
are giving it them on bringing new
things that you've never even thought of
and yeah there was improv involved and
just acting is reacting so so the fact
that you get to react to Don Johnson
being hilarious is you know very special
and it obviously changes your
performance versus when you're doing it
in your room
you